in ukraine the government says president
vladimir zelinsky was in a car accident
overnight but he was not seriously hurt
it says that a car ran into zielinski's
vehicle in a motorcade in the capital of
kiev imagine being the driver of the
other car the president had just
returned from isiam that's one of the
towns in northeastern ukraine that was
recaptured from russia in recent days
deborah patra was there and spoke to
zielinski during his surprise visit
a strong message from president
zielinski to vladimir putin ukraine
intends to keep russian troops on the
run delivered in action as he visited
the battlefields of newly liberated
towns in harkeef president zielinski
and in this brief but frank encounter on
a partially destroyed bridge in isiam
fighting words you see that russia's
destroyed
and you see the massable strategy but
the main thing that we are coming back
and we are on the way to the end
russians held this town for over six
months and just a few days ago this
would have been unthinkable
even now the visit was bold little more
than six miles from the nearest front
line occasional shelling can still be
heard new friend city zoom free ukraine
army very best
and it was a boost to troop morale
ukrainian soldier nazar was part of the
surprise counter-offensive
he told us they out-maneuvered russia
making them believe the action would be
in a different region southern her son i
think it was a part of plan you beat the
russians at their own disinformation yes
for many of the residents it's been
nearly seven months of hell lisa yakina
showed us the icy basement where she hid
with 50 neighbors for over 100 days it
was horrible
cold
without
water sometimes without electricity
and pointed out the shallow grave they
dug for a woman who died because she
could not get life-saving medication
russian artillery has laid waste to
civilian targets here homes hospitals
schools and pedestrian bridges
amid the destruction children barely
flinch at the distant sound of
explosions
preoccupied with turning weapons of war
into youthful boyish games
there is still fear here that although
putin's forces have fled they could plan
some kind of retaliation and just last
night around eight russian missiles hit
a hydropower plant in zielinski's
hometown of pv causing flooding in that
area tony
deborah pada for us more haunting
pictures from ukraine deborah thank you
very much